suivez-moi
j'aimerais vous travaillez pour moi
quel travail à grand gaube l'anarchiste
et me renseigner sur eux
pourquoi moi
des anglais la tête de l'emploi nous
inspirer confiance j'ai l'espoir d'une
organisation sociale dans laquelle
personne ne contrôle personnes et où
chacun ce contrôle soit même musique et
amassé grâce à cet homme je suis là je
compte bien lui servir à boire à la
voulais pas me relâcher plus je veux
tout savoir
tous ici si vous voulez leur part il
faut leur ressemble et sinon ils auront
toutes riches
qu'est ce que tu fais là
ce que tu cherches
pourquoi t'es tu ne reviens pas
estimé saint gély supporte pas qu'il
disait à la bonne
boehner ckoi cessé de s'embrasser se
penser
c'est de vivre quand le bonheur d'être
libre
qui en est
si vous faites ça je vais vous voir les
gens disent que les anarchies sont des
fous mais c'est vrai
cette foule est toujours un système
toujours tomber à moi et c'est un truc
tu vois là comme des véhicules déjà été
amoureux trash
moi je tenais
trop tard pour les arrêter plus
anarchiste public que rien du tout
c'est en mai pour moi
jeu de cubes et judith